the show opens up in the bustling New
York Times Square where a police officer
spots an unattended duffel bag lying in
the middle of the street he tries to
find the owner by questioning the nearby
pedestrians but nobody claims it upon
approaching the bag the officer
shockingly notices a tag with the words
contact the FBI concerned that it might
contain dangerous explosives the area is
immediately evacuated and the bomb squad
is called in for investigation a
specialist cautiously approaches the bag
and scans it with his device but finds
no evidence of danger however during a
manual inspection the bag unexpectedly
moves startling the officer for a moment
soon after the bag unzips from the
inside revealing a naked woman adorned
with numerous tattoos on her she appears
to be confused by the situation but the
cops take her into custody anyways they
had no real reason to but I'm sure they
were quick to come up with an excuse the
scene then shifts to a rural house in
Kentucky where an armed man has
restrained multiple women as well as
their babies by handcuffing and chaining
them amidst the cries of terrified Women
and Infants a team of FBI officers led
by an agent named Kurt Weller storms the
house Kurt swiftly devises a plan and
uses a detector to locate the criminal's
position he breaks through the
identified Point causing the armed man
to fall and be apprehended following
this successful Rescue Mission and once
he'd uncuffed those babies Kurt is
immediately airlifted by a helicopter in
order to assist with the case at Times
Square upon his arrival a head agent
named Bethany Mayfair briefs Kurt on the
tattooed woman whose name is revealed to
be Jane Doe they're soon joined by a
doctor who discloses that Jane has been
administered a substance called Zeta
interacting protein or zip
an experimental drug in 10 for people
suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorder while the drug is meant to
selectively diminish specific memories
when taken in small doses Jane has been
exposed to an excess amount of it the
doctor explains that there is a
possibility that something might trigger
Jane Doe's memory although even He is
uncertain as it is a peculiar case agent
Bethany then takes Kurt to meet Jane and
inquires if he recognizes her Kurt
states that he does not know her but to
his surprise the woman has a tattoo of
his name on her
Kurt has a drinking problem in the next
scene Kurt directs his team members to
search the FBI databases for any matches
related to Jane's appearance and her
Biometrics when it proves fruitless she
orders them to retrieve the CCTV footage
from Times Square so that they can
identify the person who left the duffel
bag back in the laboratory area agent
Patterson carefully examines Jane's body
and discovers that all her tattoos are
recent they were actually made within
the last week on analyzing the tattoos
further Kurt deduces that they likely
form a map or puzzle that needs to be
deciphered later on Kurt enters Jane's
chamber and inquires the reason for
having his name tattooed on her Jane
reaches out to touch Kurt's hand and
feel his face but she struggles to
recollect any information from the past
aware that she has nowhere to go the FBI
arranges for her to stay in a secure
residence that night Jane gazes at her
reflection in the mirror and breaks down
in tears overwhelmed by the fact that
she cannot remember anything the
following day Jane engages in a therapy
session with Doctor Who presents her
with a choice between two drinks in
response she chooses coffee which makes
her realize that she is a coffee person
as a result the doctor advises her to
continue exploring new experiences that
might trigger her memories while also
reassuring her that even if her past
remains elusive she can still discover
her true self she could pick between an
apple and a banana think of the
epiphanies later that day as Kurt and
his team are reviewing some photographs
Jane suddenly enters the room with some
she is able to identify one of the
tattoos on the back of her ears composed
of Chinese characters I don't even know
what the back of my ears look like she
reads the characters aloud which turn
out to be an address and a date the
strange thing is that the date is of
this very day Kurt and his group quickly
search for the address and learn that it
belongs to a Chinese guy named Chao who
is an employee of a multinational
corporation General Electric without any
delay the FBI team along with Jane heads
on a mission to locate ciao upon arrival
at the subtle location they encounter
chao's roommate who talks only in
Chinese surprisingly Jane serves as a
translator and relays to the FBI members
that the roommate has not seen Shao
since the day before following this the
FBI team breaks into Chaz room and
discovers a small laboratory for
manufacturing methamphetamine along with
traces of explosive chemicals in
addition they find a laptop protected by
a password one of the officers
immediately begins to crack it back at
the FBI headquarters agent Patterson and
Bethany make a discovery an additional
concealed tattoo depicting a Navy SEAL
this Revelation prompts them to
speculate whether Jane might have a
connection to the Navy SEAL Bethany
believes that Jane could be part of a
special operations unit which would
explain why her database yielded no
results for her meanwhile as Kurt and
the team conducted their investigation
Jane Waits outside the room during this
time she overhears the building's
manager mistreating his wife she tries
to ignore it for a while but when sounds
keep getting louder she Springs into
action to everyone's surprise Jane
showcases her remarkable combat skills
and subdues two assailants alone this
further proves that Jane is affiliated
with the Navy Seals soon after Kurt
Witnesses the altercation so he
immediately steps into restrain Jane
before escorting her to Chow's room
turns out that they have found a video
on Sha's computer that requires
translation once deciphered the video
reveals that Xiao is planning to Target
a famous politician referred to as the
mother of Exiles within the next three
and a half hours Kurt believes that the
intended target is Senator Judith Moore
a vocal advocate for immigration and
Chinese trade she is the only Marquee
female politician in New York after a
bit of Investigation the FBI realizes
that Xiao has powered off his phone and
that all of his emails are written in
Benjo which is also known as the devil's
language I'm not sure if that's true but
it sounds offensive moments later they
managed to root xiao's phone and
reactivate it enabling them to trace his
whereabouts with this Kurt and the team
had on a mission to apprehend Xiao while
Bethany arranges for additional security
to protect Senator Moore in the next
scene the team locates ciao in the
subway and discreetly begins to tail him
however someone manages to warn him
about the followers prompting him to
board a train and move away quickly Kurt
along with one of his colleagues goes
after him but their efforts are in vain
as Chow cleverly uncouples the train and
escapes he also manages to leave behind
a Time explosive device now with time
running out Kurt frantically orders the
passengers to move back while he himself
grabs the bomb and carries it away from
the train he then removes a portion of
the C4 explosive hoping it will lessen
the impact and just in the nick of time
he hurls the bomb away averting the
potential Devastation it would have
caused cable TV is like comic books but
for grown-ups who are dumb as balls in
the aftermath of this incident Jane
reads through Chow's emails and
discovers his profound anguish over his
mother's death in a Chinese prison camp
it is revealed that Xiao and his sister
had asked the United States government
for assistance but their pleas went
unanswered upon learning this Kurt
realizes that the target is not a
politician but rather the Statue of
Liberty which is the most iconic tourist
destination in the country armed with
this newfound knowledge the FBI team
rushes to The Landmark once they arrive
Jane expresses her desire to contribute
and assist the team Kurt obliges and
gives her a bulletproof vest as the team
moves inside the Statue of Liberty Kurt
and Jane come across a man whom they
initially assumed to be a ranger Kurt
instructs him to walk out as the
location needs to be evacuated but the
man is none other than Xiao who suddenly
turns around and shoots Jane in the arm
before making his Escape upstairs
determined to end this once and for all
Kurt goes after him and the two
eventually come face to face they start
fighting and at one point ciao gains the
upper hand and prepares to execute Kurt
but right then Jane arrives at the scene
and holds ciao at gunpoint the latter
tries to manipulate her but she doesn't
listen and shoots him in the arm freeing
Kurt from his captor's clutches at the
same time Jane experiences a flashback a
black and white memory depicting her
with long hair training in Marksmanship
alongside an unidentified bearded man in
a woodland setting startled by the
sudden recollection that she used to be
colorblind Jane confides and kurd
revealing that she remembers something
significant leading to an awkward
Embrace between the two later on at the
FBI headquarters Kurt addresses the team
emphasizing that Jane possesses the
skills of a seasoned professional
including language proficiency combat
abilities and exceptional Marksmanship
he highlights the fact that one of her
tattoos played a crucial role in saving
the lives of numerous individuals after
enduring these events Kurt deduces that
the precinct can't afford her and that
the Mastermind behind all this likes
playing games and it is just the
beginning Bethany then advises everyone
to rest as they will reconvene the
following day for further investigation
and Analysis after the departure of the
team Bethany begins examining a top
secret file that contains a few
uncensored details including her own
name at the top of the file she
discovers a case number that happens to
correspond to one of Jane's tattoos on
the other hand Kurt pays a visit to
Jane's residence to ensure that she's
coping well when he notices that she is
distressed he gives her a warm hug
assuring her that everything will
eventually be all right elsewhere ciao
is shown recuperating at a hospital
following his arm surgery a few moments
later a bearded man from Jane's
flashback enters the room disguised as a
doctor upon seeing him Chao expresses
his belief that everything happened the
way it was supposed to but the bearded
man doesn't agree he asserts that Chao
was meant to sacrifice himself for his
sister following this the bearded man
murders ciao and walks away in the final
scene we see another flashback that
depicts the same bearded man explaining
the concept of zip to Jane explaining
that upon being injected with it she
would lose all of her memories
surprisingly Jane agrees to administer
the drug to herself revealing that it
was her own decision she knew that she
was going to lose her memories what's
Michael Scofield's excuse
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching